Howdy! The goal of this series of
classes is to make you fall in love with bioinformatics.
Whatever you are studying
now: computer science, or biology, or
mathematics, we want you to consider
bioinformatics as well. Why? Because
bioinformatics is a new frontier in
all of these disciplines and because it is
built on all of them. I first learned about
bioinformatics when I was completing my
PhD in discrete mathematics a quarter
century ago. And the moment I heard about
this futuristic new discipline on the
interface of computing and biology, I
instantly switched, and never looked back. At
that time, bioinformatics was an obscure
discipline, but today it is a huge field
that is making a digital revolution
in biology and that opened the era of
personalized medicine. But one thing has
not changed: bioinformatics remains the
same frontier, the same Wild West, as it
was a quarter century ago; and that is
why we are wearing these crazy outfits ...
... you mean, apart from the fact that they
look good on us. Sure! In this specialization we're
going to discuss many questions that are
asked in modern biology and medicine
such as "Which animal gave us SARS?" or "Do
we have a clock gene?" or "How is it that
we find disease-causing mutations?" After
we ask each of these biological
questions we'll then learn about the
computational approaches that are used
to solve them, from clustering algorithms
to evolutionary tree construction to
machine learning approaches. Along the
way we're going to travel back in time
to solve a 300 year-old mathematical
problem,
wander around Manhattan as tourists,
we'll even get lost in a Japanese casino
run by yakuza! All of these adventures
may sound like risky propositions, but we
hope that you will join us to see what
they have to do with bioinformatics.
Although these instructors may appear
crazy, they are not quite as mad as they
look.
Dr. Pavel Pevzner is a Distinguished
Professor of computer science at the
University of California San Diego and a
leading authority on bioinformatics.
He's dressed this way because he sometimes
thinks that he's a sheriff of
bioinformatics. a frontier discipline
underpinning the digital revolution in
biology and personalized medicine. Dr.
Phillip Compeau is an assistant teaching professor
of Computational Biology at Carnegie Mellon
University. To learn why he is dressed
this way you'll need to take this course
or read the textbook,
Bioinformatics Algorithms: An Active Learning Approach,
co-authored by the two speakers.